the path that led me to create CBA with
colleagues was
I was what's called a junior fellow at
Harvard I was visiting MIT through
Marvin because I was interested in the
physics and musical instruments I
this will be another slight aggression I
uh and Cornell I would study Physics and
and then I would cross the street and go
to the music department where I played
the bassoon and I would trim reads and
play the reads and they'd be beautiful
but then they'd get soggy and then I
discovered in the basement of the music
department at Cornell was David Borden
uh who you might not have heard of but
his legendary electronic music because
he was really the first electronic
musician so Bob Moog who invented um
Moog synthesizers was a physics student
at Cornell like me crossing the street
and eventually he was kicked out and
invented electronic music David Borden
was the first musician who created
electronic music so he's legendary for
people like Phil glass and Steve Reich
and so that got me thinking about I
would behave as a scientist in the music
department but not in in the physics
department but not in the music
department got me thinking about what's
the computational capacity of a musical
instrument
and through Marvin he introduced me to
Todd mackover at the media lab who was
just about to start a project with Yo-Yo
Ma
um that led to a collaboration uh to
instrumenticello to to extract yoyo's
data and bring it out into computational
environments what is the computational
capacity of a musical instrument as we
continue on this tangent and when we
shall return to CBA yeah so
one part of that is to understand the
Computing and if you look at like the
finest time scale and length scale you
need to model the physics it's not
heroic you know a a good GPU can do
teraflops today that used to be a
national class supercomputer now it's
just a GPU and that's about if you take
the time scales and length scales
relevant for the physics that's about
the scale of the physics Computing for
yoyo it was really driving it was he's
completely unsentimental about the strad
it's not that it makes some magical
Wiggles in the sound wave it's its
performance as a controller how he can
manipulate it as an interface device
interface between one and one exactly
human sound okay and so so what it led
to was I had started by thinking about
Ops per second but the yoyo's question
was really
um resolution and bandwidth it's
um how fast can you measure what he does
and
um uh the the the bandwidth and the
resolution of detecting his controls and
then mapping them into sounds and what
what we found what he found was if you
instrument everything he does and
connect it to almost anything it sounds
like yo-yo that that the magic is in the
control not in ineffable details in how
the wood Wiggles and so with yo-yo and
Todd that led to a piece and towards the
end I asked yo-yo what what it would
take for him to get rid of his Strat and
use our stuff and his answer was just
Logistics it was at that time our stuff
was like a rack of electronics and lots
of cables and some grad students to to
make it work once the technology becomes
as invisible as the strad then sure
absolutely he would take it and by the
way as a footnote on the footnote an
accident in the sensing of yoyo's cello
led to a hundred million dollar a year
Auto Safety business to control airbags
and cars how did that work I had to
instrument the bow without interfering
with it so I um set up
um local electromagnetic fields where I
would um detect
um how those fields interact with the
bow he's playing but we had a problem
that his hand whenever his hand got near
these sensing Fields I would start
sensing his hand rather than the
materials on the bow
and I didn't quite understand what was
going on with those that that
interference so my very first grad
student ever Josh Smith
did a thesis on tomography with electric
Fields how to see in 3d with electric
fields
then through Todd and at that point
research scientists my lab Joe Paradiso
it led to a collaboration with uh Penn
and Teller who
um where we did a magic trick in Las
Vegas to contact Houdini and sort of
these fields are sort of like you know
contacting spirits
so we did a magic trick in Las Vegas and
then the the crazy thing that happened
after that was uh Phil ritmuller came
running into my lab he worked with
um this became with Honda and NEC
airbags were killing infants and
rear-facing child seats
um cars need to distinguish
a front-facing adult where you'd save
the life versus a bag of groceries where
you don't need to fire the airbag versus
the rear-facing infant where you would
kill it and so the the the seat need to
in effect see in 3d to understand the
occupants and so we took the pen and
Teller magic trick derived from Josh's
thesis from yo-yo's Cello to an auto
show and all the card companies said
great when can we buy it and so that
became ellisis and it was 100 million
dollar a year business making sensors
there wasn't a lot of publicity because
it was in the car so the car didn't kill
you
so they didn't sort of advertise we have
nice sensors so the car doesn't kill you
but it became a leading Auto Safety
sensor and that started from the cello
and the question of the computational
capacity musical instrument right